نذهب الان الى كلمه الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان لاعلان المرسوم الرئاسي
للانتخابات
الذي نغير الموعد هو موعد
الامتحانات
الجامعيه
الثانويه بالاضافه الى
موعد
الحج ايضا
بالاضافه الى بعض الاسباب الاخرى من ضمنها
الاختبارات
الثانويه والاعداديه في المراحل التعليميه
كما انه سيتم التوجه الى
المدن الاخرى وايضا البلدان الاخرى بسبب
الحركه السياحيه لذلك استطعنا ان نغير
موعد الانتخابات من شهر حزيران وقمنا
بتقديمه الى الرابع عشر من شهر مايو كان
هناك بعض البدائل وهو موعد 14 من ماي وذلك
حسب
التاريخ التركي ايضا حيث له اهميه
التاريخيه ايضا واعتقد ان هذا الموعد هو
مرغوب به من قبل الشعب التركيه ايضا ولكن
كما تعلمون بسبب الكارثه التي وقعت في
مناطق الجنوبيه من تركيا في مدينه
هاتايما وملاطيا وكهرمان مرعش واسمانيا
وشان اورفاوه غازي عنتاب
حيث كنا نتساءل عما اذا كنا قادرين على
قيام هذه الانتخابات ايضا في الموعد
المحدد وهو الرابع عشر من شهر مايو لذلك
قمنا
التفكير جيدا وتمعن جيدا في هذا الموعد
كيف سيتم الاستعداد للانتخابات ولكن كانت
الاولويه
لتقديم كل ما يمكن من دعم للمتضررين من
الزلازل بالاضافه الى المساحه الواسعه
التي تسببت بها الدمار هذه ازاله علينا ان
نلجا
لتقديم كل الامكانيات للمساهمه في البحث
والانقاذ وايضا تقديم المساعدات للمواطنين
المتضررين من هنا اسال الله الرحمه
للمتوفين جراء هذه العزل
والصبر والسلوانه لاهالي
الشفاء العاجل للجراحه ملايين الناس في
هذه المناطق فقدوا منازلهم
وانهارت منازلهم بشكل كامل او تضررت بشكل
كبير
منذ اللحظات الاولى لوقوع هذه الكارثه
توجهنا الى هذه المناطق المنكوبه بكل
امكانياتنا حكومه وشعبا ووقفنا الى جانب
اخواننا المتضررين من هذه
الحكومه التركيه كرست كل امكانياتها
وقدراتها لتقديم الدعم للمتضررين من
الزلازل وهناك ايضا دعم دولي كبير جدا
وجهود مبذوله لتقديم
المساعدات بالاضافه الى البحث والانقاذ
والان يتم العمل على رفع الانقاذ وبناء
المنازل الجديده كما تعلمون كما انه
التقديم كل المواد الاغاثيه والطبيه وايضا
يتم العمل على اليات جديده لتقديم هذا
الدعم المتضررين من اعزل طبعا هناك كما
نزل مسبقه الصنع كما تعلمون يتم الان
تقديمها الى المتدرين من اجل اضافه الى
الخيام طبعا يتم العمل على بناء
المنازل الدائمه التي ستكتمل خلال عام
واحد تقريبا بالاضافه الى المنازل الاخرى
التي ستكتمل ايضا خلال الفتره المقبله
هو الهدف الاساسي
اكمال اكثر من 300 الف منزل خلال عام واحد
وايضا كما انه سيتم العمل على اعاده بناء
اكثر من 800 الف منزل
الامر اشبه باعاده هيكله هذه المدن
المتضرره بالاضافه الى المدن الاخرى التي
سيتم فيها اتباع مشاريع
التحول الحضري واعاده بناء منازل امنه
وجديده
وبالاضافه الى المرافق الاجتماعيه
المتينه التي ستقاوم الزلازل القادمه طبعا
هذا التحول الحضري وهذا المشروع سيتم
العمل عليه في المدن الاخرى في عموم
البلاد
[موسيقى]
اللحظات الاولى لوقوع هذه الكارثه على
مساعده الناس المتضررين من الزلازل ولكن
كنا من جانبا اخر نستمر بالعمل على تحديد
موعد الانتخابات وايضا
النظر فيما اذا كان ممكن ان تقام هذه
الانتخابات في الموعد المحدد ام لا ولكن
بالطبع كانت
كانت هناك تاثيرات مباشره وغير مباشره
للزل وبالتالي كنا
ندقق في كل
التفاصيل
ضروري النظر فيها ويتم من خلالها اتخاذ
القرارات
وايضا التدابير اللازمه ضمن هذه الفتره
كما تعلمون هناك بعض التوترات السياسيه
من الممكن ان تحصل وهذا ما حصل بعد وقوع
زلازل كما تعلمون ولكن استطعت الحكومه
التركيه ان
تركز اولا على رفع كل الاثار السلبيه
لازلزل لتنظر فيما بعد في الامور الاخرى
من ضمنها الانتخابات والامور الاخرى
بينكم
كان هناك جزء كبير تضرر من ازلازل بين بين
اطياف الشعب بسبب ازاله المدمر كما تعلمون
ولكن كانت هناك ايضا
الجزئيه الاخرى التي كانت تستغل هذه
الكارثه لمصالحها السياسيه ولكن من
الضروري ان نعلم جيدا ان ليس لدينا الوقت
لصرف الطاقه
كل الامكانيات لاضاعه الوقت علينا ان نضمت
جروح المواطنين المتضررين من علينا ان
نعيد اعمار هذه المدن المتضرره والزياده
العمل
وزياده فرص العمل وايضا فرص الانتاج في كل
المناطق المتضرره بالاضافه الى المناطق
الاخرى وبهذه
السياسه
وهذا المنظور بالاضافه الى استنادنا الى
الماده 116 من الدستور التركي تم تحديد
موعد 14 مايو للانتخابات المقبله
مع ظهور القرار الذي وقعنا عليه الان في
اجره الرسميه سيتم ايضا اعلان الدعايات
الانتخابيه والقرارات الملحقه بقرار
الانتخابات وقانون الانتخابات وطبعا من
المتوقع ايضا انه سيتم اعلان كل التفاصيل
المرفقه بقرار الانتخابات علي ان اذكركم
ببعض النقاط وهي في مرحله الانتخابات
سنركز على
جروح
المتضررين من الزلازل وطبعا هناك بعض
الاضرار الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه التي
ترافق
المدمره
واثار المدمره في البلاد لذلك ربما هناك
بعض الممثلين من المعارضه لدى لديهم
تصريحات
جدا هم لا يعلمون اين كنا
ومتى كنا نتواجد في منطقه ازلازل اليوم
الاول توجه زملائي الوزراء بشكل
كبير
وبذو الساعات الاولى لوقوع هذه الكارثه كل
السياسيين وكل البيروقراطيين بالاضافه الى
الموظفين ورؤساء البلديات
واستطاعوا ان ينصقوا عمليات البحث
والانقاذ منذ الساعات الاولى وانا في
اليوم الثاني توجهت فورا الى
المدن المتضرره في جوله
لعشر مدن وبعد ذلك قمت بجوله ثانيه مع
السيد
وهو عضو في تحالف الشعب كما تعلمون وايضا
نحن كنا مجروحين ولكن
سيده التي تمثل المعارضه كانت تتحدث
بشكل غير مقبول وايضا النائب البرلمانيه
عن مدينه هاتاي كانت تتحدث بشكل غريب جدا
وغير مفهوم ولكن نحن كانت لدينا كل الخطط
وكل التنسيقيات
لتنسيق عمليات البحث والانقاذ وتقديم
المساعدات الاغاثيه بالاضافه الى اعاده
الاعمار
اتصلت
نائبه برلمانيه
وطلبت
ان تحدثني بشكل مباشر
وافقت فورا على الاتصال وذكرت لي انه لا
توجد هناك اي مشاكل ولا يوجد هناك اي نقص
وذكرت لي انها تقيم في مخيم
ورغم اقامتها في المخيم قالت
انها بحاله جيده ولا باس بها واذا كانت
هناك منازل مسبقه الصنع هذه المنازل
المتنقله وقالت انها من مدينه هاتاي من
مدينه من المدينه التي تعرضت لدمار كبير
بسبب ازال اجل
هذه النائبه البرلمانيه هي من هاتاي وتلك
ايضا من مدينه هاتاي علينا ان نكون صريحين
علينا ان نكون صادقين علينا ان نكون
واضحين تسال ماذا يوجد في اسكندرون يوجد
في مدينه اسكندرون سفينه لتقدم كل
المساعدات الاغاثيه والطبيه وايضا
الاقامات المؤقته وتوجد فيها المخيمات كما
توجد فيها المنازل المتنقل نعم انا زرت
مدينه اسكندرون ولكن هي لا تعلم فماذا عسى
ان افعل
زملائي يستمرون بالتقديم كل المساعد ات
الى هذه المدن وينسقون اعمل
المساعدات
والخدمات الاغاثيه والطبيه وما شبه الجميع
يعمل عدد كبير من الوزراء يتواجدون هناك
انتم تعلمون جيدا
ولكن كما ذكرت نحن في حاله صعبه نحن لدينا
الام نحن نعاني ويا هذا الشعب الذي تضرر
من هذه الزلازل وفقد كل ما لديه لذلك
لا نستطيع ان ننشغل بهذه الاقاويل
السياسيه التي ليس لها اي مغزى ولا معنى
سوى
الشائعات ونشر هذه الشائعات منطقه
انطاكيا الواقعه في مدينه هاتاي هي من
اكثر المناطق المتضرره جراء هذه الزلازل
نحن نتجول وتجولنا والان في الايام
القادمه سابدا بالجوله الثالثه ساتجول
مجددا لابحث ما اذا كان هناك اي نقص او اي
مشاكل لاقوم بحل هذه على ارض الواقع بشكل
مباشر
واياكم الان هذا الخطاب الذي اعلنا من
خلاله الرئيس التركي رجب طيب ارجو
موعد اجراء الانتخابات الرئاسيه في الرابع
عشر من مايو قال بان قرار التقديم موعد
الانتخابات التركيه يستند الى الدستور
التركي تناول ايضا
الرئيس التركي بعض ما وصف بعض القرارات
التي اتخذت لبناء المساكن الجديده في
المناطق المنكوبه بالزلزال وان ذلك
سينتهي خلال عام واحد اذا وحسب هذا
الاعلان فاجراء الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه في تركيا سيتم في 14 من ماي
المقبل
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]